نعم نشاهد الان وجود العائلات وبعض
القناصل والسفراء لاستقبال رعاياهم نتحدث
عن 14 جنسيه متواجده على متن هذه السفينه
كما ترصد امامكم كاميرا العربيه هذه
اللقطات الحصريه والخاصه لهؤلاء العائلات
والرعاء والقناصل والمسؤولين في السفارات
الاجنبيه لاستقبال رعاياهم والاطمئنان
عليهم اريد ان اخذ لقاء الان نعم يعني اذا
كان هناك من امكانيه لقاء ومن ثم اعود
واسالك عن الاوضاع الصحيه وكيف يتم
اذا كان هناك من تواجد ايضا لاي حاله صحيه
اذا كان هناك من تواجد لمنظمات هي التي
تهتم بامورهم الصحيه اليك سلطان
نعم نؤكد انه الحكومه السعوديه ممثله
بكافه قطاعاتها الامنيه والصحيه هي
متواجده للتعامل مع كافه الحالات الصحيه
ان وجدت ان كان هنالك اصابات او جروح
لهؤلاء الرعايه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
هنالك اصابات او جرحه على متن كافه السفن
البحريه التي قامت باجلاء الرعايه من خلال
يومين الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه من السودان
بدات ان نتعرف عليك
نائب القنصل العراقي في جده اليوم على متن
السفينه جلاله الملك ينبع نشاهد رعايه
عراقيين كيف تمت عمليه التنسيق بين
الحكومه السعوديه والحكومه العراقيه لقد
تمت عمليه التنسيق على اعلى المستويات
وكانت رده فعل سريعا ومباشره جدا من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهذه المبادره الانسانيه التي اطلقها خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك محمد سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهده الامين محمد الامير محمد
بن سلمان وهذا هو هذا ما عودتنا عليه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه من رده
فعل انسانيه شملت كل كل الجنسيات ليست لم
تقتصر على دوله عربيه انما شملت كافه
الجنسيات وهذا ما نراه الان الان بام
اعيننا نرى ان كل جنسيات موجوده على هذا
المرفق وهذا الميناء لاستقبال رعاياها
وهذا ما عودتنا عليه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الشقيقه بانها صاحبه المبادرات
الانسانيه واغلى ما يكون هو انقاذ النفس
البشريه والانسان وهذا ما رايناه الان
شكرا للمملكه العربيه السعوديه حكومه
وشعبا شكرا لكم
عفوا كيف سوف يتم التعامل مع الرعايه
العراقيه طبعا اكيد احنا هناك امور
بالتعاون مع وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه امور
لوجستيه منظمه ان شاء الله سيتم اخلائهم
من هنا ومن ثم ترتيب عودتهم الى العراق
وان شاء الله ان شاء الله يرجعون سالمين
امنين الى الديار وكل الجنسيات العربيه
شكرا لك كما نشاهد هنا الجانب العراقي
وايضا جنسيات مختلفه وقناصل يتواجدون
لاستقبال رعاياهم فور نزولهم من هذه
السفينه ايضا نتحدث عن اجراءات كبرى يتم
العمل عليها من قبل الحكومه السعوديه
وكذلك
الجهات المعنيه الموجوده بمختلف اشكالها
اذا تحدثنا على وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
وكافه القناصر والسفارات الاجنبيه في
السعوديه لاستقبال رعاياهم لا لا شيء هنا
يطغى سوى على سوى مشاعر الفرح التي تتسم
على وجوه الرعايه وعلى وجوه اهاليهم وكذلك
القناصر التي تتواجدون حاليا من 14 دوله
مختلفه ايضا الان سوف ناخذكم او سوف نحاول
الوصول الى داخل او اخذكم معنا في جوله
خاصه وحصريه الى داخل سفينه جلاله الملك
ينبع لنشاهد معكم الاعداد الكبيره
للرعايه واختلاف جنسياتهم لنشاهدهم ونتاكد
من سلامتهم وكذلك وصولهم ونزولهم بشكل
كبير جدا ايضا نتحدث عن عمليات اجلاء
مستمره كما نوهنا في وقت سابق الان لحظات
محدوده وبسيطه جدا سوف يقومون بالنزول عبر
هذا السلم الذي تم وضعه الان وهو بهذا
الشكل وبهذا التصميم لسلامه نزولهم بشكل
كبير جدا ايضا يتواجد القوات البحريه وعدد
من الموظفين المدنيين
لاستقبالهم والتاكد من سلامتهم ونزولهم
بشكل كبير جدا ايضا نتحدث عن انه العدد
شخص سوف يقومون القوات البحريه السعوديه
بعمليات انزالهم بشكل سلس وكبير جدا ايضا
لحظات هي محدوده تم الانتهاء من تركيب
السلم الخاص بعمليات النزول والان سوف
ننقل معكم الصوره الحيه
والمباشره صوره الحيه والمباشره لعمليات
النقل الان سوف ننتقل معكم كما تشاهدون
الان
الان نشاهد الان الان الان نعم
الان سوف نظهر معكم الان سوف نقوم بالدخول
وصولا الى الان لحظات بسيطه وسوف نقوم
بعمليه الدخول الى علامه السفينه جلاله
الملك ينبع وصولا الى الرعايه والالتقاء
بهم والتاكد وسلامتهم وصحتهم بشكل مباشر
معكم الان نعم الان نستقل معكم هذا السلم
وصولا لقطات خاصه
وحصريه للعربيه كاول كاميرا تصل على متن
او تصل الى متن متن سفينه جلاله الملك
ينبع لنشاهد معكم هذه اللقطات الحصريه بعد
ثواني مع دوده لنشاهد الرعايه ونشاهد كيف
هي صحتهم وكيف تمت عمليات
الاجلاء والنقل لهم من بورت سودان وصولا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده لحظات بسيطه الان سوف نصل شكرا لكم
تسهيلات كبيره من قبل
التسهيلات كبيره من قبل القوات البحريه
لدخولنا على هذه السفينه مشكورين الان
نشاهد القوات الخاصه المسؤوله عن تامين
عمليات
وصول هؤلاء الرعايه بكل يسر
وسلاما نشاهد تجهيزات كبيره جدا من قبلهم
نشاهد الان
لقطات حيه ومباشره للرعايه على يسار
الكاميرا كما نشاهد الان هؤلاء بجنسيتهم
طبعا الاطفال
وكبار سن وعائلات يتم استقبالهم بالاعلام
السعوديه وبالحلوه
يتقطع سلطان ولكن ما زلنا نحن مع هذه
الصوره يعني على الرغم من تقطعها ولكن ما
زلنا نتابع معك هذه الصوره
ساتركك الى حد ما ان تصل بين
الرعايه الذين وصلوا الان علامات سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه نعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بانه هناك
يعني العديد من الجنسيات الذين وصلوا على
متن هذه السفينه وايضا كان هناك
واضحه الان الصوره واضحه سلطان نعم
الان الصوره واضحه
نتعرف عليك اسمك ايه
وانت اسمك ايه
يا رفيده من فلسطين اهلا وسهلا هؤلاء
العائله هي من فلسطين كما تشاهدون كيف تمت
عمليه اجلائكم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
من شو اسمه من
الخرطوم لبورسودان ومن بورسودان شو اسمه
الخدمات اللي قدمت لكم اثناء الرحله
الحمدلله يعني نشكر سياده شو اسمه اول شيء
نشكر الملك العربي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لانه كان شو اسمه كثير كثير
كويسين معنا والحمد لله كانت معامله احسن
من هيك ما في شكرا اله كما تشاهدونها
امامكم بعض مشاعر الفرح ممكن نلتقي ببعض
العائلات الموجوده معنا اليوم ممكن نتعرف
عليك
انا احلام من سوريا احلام من سوريا كيف
تمت عمليه اجلائك يا احلام الى من الخرطوم
الى بورسودان الى جده تم الاتفاق مع
السفاره اللبنانيه والسفيره اللبنانيه
عملت اتصالاتها مع السعوديه مشكورين كتير
على كل شيء قدمتوه من جهدك نحن بنشكركم
كثير من قلبنا
الخرطوم ما في
قصف عشوائي يعني على اولادنا وعلى حالنا
انه تشتد الاشتباكات بيناتهم عرفت كيف
حرام حرام السودان يكون صار فيها هيك وكم
عدد اطفالك معك انا معي هلا ولا ابني
وبنتي وجوزي الحمد لله على السلامه نورتوا
السعوديه كما تشاهدون جنسيات مختلفه
ومشاعر مختلفه ايضا نستضيف معنا احدى
الاشخاص الموجود يتعرف عليك محمد مالك من
سوريا ونعم محمد انت ايش طبيعه عملك في
السودان انا رحت اناقش
انت ما تنساها في الخرطوم وش اللي اختلف
معك بعد ما وصلت قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده
اذا ما زالت الصوره تتقطع نحن بانتظار
وصلنا لقاعده
يوم وصلنا للقاعده منك بالسعوديه الحمد
لله يعني ما قصروا السفير كان موجود
والملحق العسكري كان موجود والحمد لله
كانت الامور وايد زينه شكرا لك لا اعلم هل
الصوره لا تتقطع ام واضحه صوت وصوره لذيذ
الان جيده
[موسيقى]
نعم نشاهد الان الاطفال هم يحملون الاعلام
السعوديه او كما تشاهدون مشاعر الفرح
والطمانينه والامان تتسم على وجه هؤلاء
الاطفال الذين عاشوا بطبيعه الحال ظروف
مختلفه وصعبه جدا ممكن نلتقي بهذا الشخص
نتعرف عليك
السلام عليكم بسم الله انور بن شعبان
مستشار بالسفاره الليبيه الخرطوم اليوم
104 ليبيا على متن هذه السفينه ما هي
طبيعه عملك السودان وعدد اطفالك وكيف تمت
عمليه النقل ولما وصلت قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه ايش اول شيء يعني جاء في بالك
حاليا اول شيء هو الشكر الجزيل للقياده
والشعب السعودي على الجهود اللي بدلت في
سبيل اجلال رعايه الليبيين 104 شخص طبعا
طلقنا من يوم الخميس صباحا الى يوم الجمعه
رحله طويله لمده 25 ساعه الى مدينه
بورسودان وبعد ذلك بقينا ثلاثه ايام حتى
تمت عمليه
الجلاع بوصول السفينه ينبع
نقدملهم كامل الشكر الطاقم وكبت السفينه
على الجهود اللي بدلوها في سبيل راحت
ومساعده جميع الرعايه الليبيين شخص يمثلون
طاقم السفاره بالكامل
وموظفين ومداراه شركات يعملون بالسودان
والشكر الجزيل هؤلاء بناتك نتعرف عليكم
[موسيقى]
بعد ما طلعتي على سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع
اختلف معاك الوضع ارتحتي كثير فينا ارتحت
ابدا لن يعني تتوانى بتقديم العون لاي شخص
يحتاج هذه السعوديه هذه ولا تامرنا الحمد
لله الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعطيك
العافيه كما نشاهد مشاعر مختلفه وقيادات
امنيه كبيره على متن هذه السفينه للتاكد
من تلبيه وسلامه كافه احتياجات هؤلاء
الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم كما نشاهد الان
هذا الرجل المقعد الكبير السن تقدم له
كافه الخدمات له
السعوديه هذا السعودية ما عمره تدخلت باي
شيء الا اتمته على اعلى درجه من العمل
والاحترافيه والامن والامان انت في ارض
الامن والامان في ارض الحرمين
المره الثانيه انا عامل عمليه في خروجتي
في رمضان الماضيه في مكه ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه هذه بعض المشاهد
واللقطات
الالتقاطات واللقاءات مع بعض الرعايه من
قبل المسلمين الحكومين السعوديين كما
نشاهد الجميع هنا ليتاكد اطمئن على سلامه
الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم واعمارهم ايضا
نشاهد كذلك اعداد كبيره على متن السفينه
يستعدون
بحقائبهم للنزول العلاقه نزول في قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه
خلال لحظات بعد استقبالهم بالورود
والاعلام والحلوى ايضا كما نشاهد مراحل
عمريه مختلفه واطفال
وكذلك فيما يتعلق في حال وجود العائلات
والاطفال في مناطق الصراع او مناطق الحروب
هي بطبيعه الحال تسبب ازمه كبيره لذويهم
ولعائلاتهم ولكن نشاهد البسمه اليوم ترسم
على اوجه الاطفال قبل كبار لبعد وصولهم
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
وتحديدا بعد وصولهم الى السعوديه وسوف
لحظه بعد لحظات قليله سوف يقومون سوف تقوم
القوات البحريه بانزال
الاطفال والعائلات
لانهاء اجراءاتهم ومن ثم للتاكد من انهاء
اجراءاتهم واصالهم الى مقرات السكن لاخذ
قسط من لفت نظري ممكن نعرف شو اللي موجود
ايش اللي موجود في الصندوق
قطه
تم اجلائها معكم
كنا بالخرطوم
وطلعنا على بور سودان
وطلعنا على الفندق عند السفير السعودي
وقدم لنا كل الشغلات الكويسه وكان معنا
يعني
بكل شيء خير يعني وقدم كل الشغلات
المستلزمات اللي احنا عايزينه
امورنا وبنشكر الملك سلمان
وابنه ومحمد ولي العهد شكرا لك يعني كما
شاهدتم الان في على الكاميرا مباشره حتى
فيما يتعلق بالحيوانات الاليفه الخاصه
بالرعايه يتم كذلك
اجلائها عبر سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع اليوم
نؤكد ونؤك ونعيد التاكيد ان الحكومه
السعوديه ممثله بوزاره الخارجيه والسفاره
السعوديه في الخرطوم وكذلك القوات البحريه
السعوديه تعمل على تلبيه كافه احتياجات
الرعايه والتسهيل لهم اثناء عمليات نقلهم
والتاكد من تلبيه احتياجاتهم
وسلامتهم ايضا نشاهد الان مشاعر
يعيش فرحه كبيره وفرحه مختلفه بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان بطبيعه الحال
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع وصول الرعايه
الاجانب وايضا بعض السعوديين على سفينه
جلاله الملك ينبع في قاعده ملك فيصل
البحريه
وطبعا العديد من الجنسيات على متن هذه
السفينه تم تقديم كل التسهيلات
لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى يصلوا بامان الى جده
ومن ثم يتم نقلهم
والى بلدانهم هناك العديد من الدبلوماسيين
والقناصل والمسؤولين من كافه الدول التي
تصل رعاياها على هذه السفينه متواجده هناك
من اجل استقبالهم وايضا انهاء كل الامور
التي لم يحتاجونها وكانت طبعا الخارجيه
السعوديه
تحدثت عن وصول هذه السفينه الى ج
وقالت بانه هناك عشره مواطنين سعوديين على
متنهم وبلغ عدد رعايه الدول طبعا الشقيقه
والصديقه التي تم اجلائهم نحو 189 شخصا
الجنسيات المتواجده على متن هذه السفينه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المملكه
المتحده السويد ايطاليا قطر
هولندا العراق تركيا تنزانيا لبنان وليبيا
وطبعا تم نقلهم عبر هذه السفينه دعونا
نذهب الى سلطان
نعم انا يعني اشاهدك يعني دموع على خديك
يعني لماذا هذه الدموع
وهلا جينا هون وحاسين بامان اول شيء بفكر
فيه انه تركناهم هنيك يا احبابنا اصعب من
انه يحسوا نفس الاحساس انه وصلنا بامانه
خير بس الحمد لله الحمد لله نشكر المملكه
العربيه السعوديه على كل قدموا لنا طلعونا
وجابونه وقعدونا الطريق كنس وما قصروا
معنا بشيء ما في خدمه طلبناها ما كانوا
موفرين لنا اياها فالحمد لله اكيد هذه
الدموع خرجت بعد معاناه كبيره عشتها في
الخرطوم طبعا اكيد اكيد تعبنا كتير تعبنا
كتير لطلعنا وبس الحمد لله يعني الواحد
ربنا معه ويسر لنا الطريق وهنا زي ما قلت
لك ابدا ما قصروا معنا يعني رحلتنا ممكن
لما طلع لهون ما حسيناها باي تعب يعني كله
خلص كان راح الحمد لله شكرا لك شكرا يعني
كما نشاهد بلقطات حيه ومباشره نعيد نؤكد
ان هنالك علاماتنا هذه السفينه
199 شخص من 14 جنسيه مختلفه من ضمنهم
عشره السعوديين تنوع كبير في الجنسيات
والرعايه واعمار مختلفه جدا كما نشاهد
امامكم ومشاعر مختلطه بالفرح والخوف
والامان بعد ان عاشوا اوقات الصعبه واليمه
في الخرطوم بشكل كبير خلال الايام الماضيه
لذلك نشاهد هذه المشاعر وكما نشاهد حتى
الاطفال اليوم باعمار مختلفه اليوم من
الاولاد والبنات الصغار باعمال مختلفه بس
نتعرف عليك لو سمحتي
[موسيقى]
كم عمر البنت اسمها
ما تكون معاك طفله في اوضاع شبيهه باوضاع
السودان قد تشعرين بقلق مختلف وكبير جدا
اللي كنا فيه ما شاء الله الله يحميهم
شعبا ودوره وحكومه
ايش طبيعه عملك وسبب وجودك في الخرطوم
وكيف كنتي عشتي لحظاته والايام الاشتباكات
المسلحه والله كنت لحظات كتير
اكل ولا نوم ولا شرب زوجي شغال هناك صالون
يعني اكثر من 15 سنه يعني
عشنا كتير ايام صعبه الله فرجها وجينا
لهون الحمد لله
يعني نحاول نلتقي بالمزيد من الرعايه
ونتنوع في الجنسيات ونحاول ان نعرف او
نكتشف مشاعرهم واحاسيسهم المختلفه التي
واللحظات الصعبه والقاسيه التي عاشوها في
الخرطوم خلال الايام الماضيه اثناء عمليات
اجلائهم ايضا نؤكد على سهوله عمليات
الاجلاء من الخرطوم
برا ومن ثم بحرا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحري
ايضا فيما يتعلق بالاطفال هنالك يعني
تعامل خاص من قبل
ومهيا لهم وكذلك توفير الاطعمه والمشروبات
وكذلك حتى
المشتقات الحليب حتى يستطيع الاطفال حتى
يتم تامين الحليب ومشتقات
الصغار سنا تحديدا
الان اعذروني على المقاطعه كما نشاهد احدى
العسكريات التابعات لقوات البحريه
السعوديه الان تحمل هذه الطفل او الطفل
وهو اعتقد انه
يشعر
بالارهاق او بالتعب او النوم وها هي
والدته الان بجانبي موجوده كما نشاهد يعني
خدمات انسانيه يعملون عليها القوات
البحريه
رجالا ونساء كخدمات انسانيه تعمل عليها
القوات البحريه قبل الخدمات الامنيه
والعسكريه للتسهيل على كافه الرعايه
بمختلف جنسياتهم ايضا نتحدث عن انه دقائق
محدوده بسيطه في ظرف
ومن ثم هنالك حافلات خاصه سوف تقوم بنقلهم
الى مقرات السكنهم فورا بعد انهاء
الاجراءات الخاصه
بهم يعني اعداد كبيره كما نشاهد الان
يستطيعون يعني كما تشاهد امامكم الان
مشاعر مختلفه اعداد كبيره لحظات محدوده
وسوف يتم انزالهم وانهاء اجراءات سفرهم
نتحد نؤكد ان عددهم مئه وتسعه وتسعين شخص
الحس الاكبر من الرعايه هم لمواطنين
الليبيين بعدد 104 وكذلك من ضمن الاعداد
او على مثل هذه السفينه عشره السعوديين
واكثر من 14 الجنسيه مختلفه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات